now I have to ask you quick Wonder Woman
question you said recently that you have
an idea for what Wonder Woman 3 will
look like yeah do you see it being
another period piece or would we perhaps
see Diana in the future um I don't
III I'm not set but I'm not dying to do
another period piece in Mike it was
funny I read article today about like
whether it would be in the future or
what it would be it's I'm not as article
actually oh yeah I didn't write it
oh yeah no exactly it was great it was a
great idea it's not it's it's definitely
one of the things we've talked about I'm
not planning to put it in the past again
because then where you gonna go I think
it's sort of it would be weird you have
to go forward so it's definitely a
contemporary story that's all I can say
and so where we put it and how that gets
figured out I haven't totally nailed
down obviously Wonder Woman had huge
success and most recently Aquaman yeah
James Wong I'm curious because it kind
of makes sense that for you or him to
direct the Justice League movie does
that interest you at all
you know the Justice League movie I find
those movies to be extremely challenging
I think they're fantastic when they're
well done but taking on all of those
characters at the same time and the
timeline I sort of hope that we don't do
a Justice League movie for a little
while because I think that each of those
characters are really great and I'm
super excited to see each of their
movies and then I want to see Aquaman 2
and I want to see flash and I want to
you know so I don't know III you never
know I would never say never but I think
that I think everybody should have a
moment to shine right now hey everybody
its charlie we've just been talking
about Aquaman 2 but surprise surprise
there's gonna be a Wonder Woman 3 if you
didn't already think there was gonna be
one and confirmed Justice League 2 but
with a couple of caveats so we got to
break this down also explain what's
going on with the other sort of DC
movies that they've been planning like
the flash movie in the Green Lantern
Corps movie and what some of the big
changes they're gonna make based on what
people have been saying about that next
Justice League movie we'll do a new
round of the Amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Wonder Woman related comment
on the video so first big thing we'll
talk about Wonder Woman 1984 and Wonder
Woman 3 then I'll talk about the Justice
League stuff what's going on in this
patty Jenkins is confirming Wonder Woman
3 is a real
I mean after the box office of the first
movie a trilogy was a foregone
conclusion but if you don't remember
they took their sweet-ass time locking
her down as the director of Wonder Woman
1984 they'd already signed gal gadot to
a multi picture deal no big surprise
there but patty Jenkins had only been
signed on for that first Wonder Woman
film it was so successful she is
probably gonna get paid some serious
cash for any other sequels that they do
same thing also just happened for Ryan
Coogler with the Black Panther franchise
it kind of happened with Robert Downey
jr. way back when when he did that first
Iron Man film they paid him like a tiny
little bit of money for that first film
then by the time age of ultron rolled
around i think he was earning fifty plus
million dollars between all of his
participation and upfront money it just
got really crazy the other big thing
that they get when they renegotiate
deals like that is directors usually get
total creative control of movies and on
that first film Zack Snyder is still
credited on the script and he was still
a producer separately this weekend Chris
Pine has done a bunch of interviews
talking about Wonder Woman - in Steve
Trevor I'll talk about the returned
fanny pack version of Steve Trevor in a
second because they're actually some
pretty solid rumors about what's going
on with his character but the most
interesting things that patty Jenkins
talks about is that Wonder Woman 3 being
set during present day she confirms No
More period film set during the past
that's what she means by saying that
it'll be contemporary meaning that the
events of that movie will be happening
concurrently with what's happening in
the Aquaman franchise and in the flash
movie
the only other film that I know of
that's being set during the past is
gonna be Matt Reeves Batman film which
is supposed to be a story from earlier
in Batman's career when he was still
back in his 20s
because Ben Affleck Batman was closer to
his 40s she also confirms they're
definitely doing the flash movie we
already knew about Aquaman 2 which she
already mentions in they're definitely
doing Justice League 2 which a lot of us
weren't really sure about like you kind
of assume like oh they got to do it at
some point but she's just saying oh yeah
it's definitely gonna happen eventually
but she's also asked about her or James
Wan possibly directing that Justice
League sequel because as of right now
they're like the two golden children of
the DC Universe directors stable so I'll
go on record as saying that I don't
think that she would be the one to
direct Justice League - not because they
wouldn't ask her to do it mostly because
I think she would decline for the
reasons that she talks about during that
interview there - man
characters to balance too many things
that can go wrong that's why she says
the big team up movies are great when
they work well quote unquote referencing
the debacle of the first Justice League
film so she's also confirming
tangentially the plan to develop each of
the separate characters in their own
movies then early prediction after we
get a Green Lantern movie Hal Jordan
John Stuart are proven successes then
they do another Justice League movie in
depending on how successful all the
other characters sequels are they lean
into the bigger team-up stories of each
of those characters so there are really
big cosmic Green Lantern stories like
war of light that you could use for your
big Justice League movies but that only
works if the Green Lantern Corps movie
winds up being a success like if it
doesn't do well then obviously they
don't want to double down on that second
early prediction what they'll probably
do is play it safe try to keep things as
simple as possible in they'll just do in
Justice League Legion of Doom with
mostly the pre established earth-based
villains like Deathstroke Lex Luthor
Black Manta ocean master and any other
big Batman villains that pop up between
now and then proven villains that work
well in the DC Universe that people like
and just have it be more of an
earth-based film then if things go
really well with Justice League 2 for
that whatever third film winds up being
then they do more cosmic stories there
is a new gods movie that they're still
making but I think that's gonna be
relatively self-contained if it does
really really well maybe they'll start
to do more cosmic stuff with the new
gods in the Justice League films but
here's the thing you probably heard the
schedule for a lot of these movies has
already changed a lot so remember when
they announced all those sequels a long
time ago you just have to kind of throw
that out and assume that they're not
gonna hit any of those dates they've
delayed Wonder Woman 1984 it's not
coming out till summer 2020 they haven't
said anything about the flash movie or
the Green Lantern Corps movie in a
little while but the flash movie was
delayed a little while ago so that Ezra
Miller could shoot the next fantastic
beasts film then he would shoot the
flash movie so as of right now there's
no way they're gonna start shooting that
flash movie till at least next year give
them about a year to turn it around
meaning the flash movie isn't dropping
until at least 2021 so early prediction
for the next Justice League movie it
happens and say like four or five years
2023 2024
and in order to make it feel very
different from the first Justice League
film you cycle the roster
a little bit meaning that because we'll
have already had our Green Lantern Corps
movie hopefully it's a success
you put Hal Jordan Green Lantern on the
team he's your tie - cosmic stories and
whoever our new Batman winds up being
after the Matt Reeves Batman movie I
still think that Henry Cavill is gonna
try and come back and be Superman but I
think by that time we'll have had our
new Batman already what I'm hoping is is
that by this summer at Comic Con
they'll have announced who's directing
the Green Lantern Corps movie they'll
have a script at least partially done in
the movie can shoot next year for a
possible 2021 release and it can be sort
of like that Aquaman style huge big
James Cameron looking avatar style movie
for outer space you have to remember the
biggest thing people have been talking
about in the Aquaman movie is how strong
the visuals are so just expect future DC
movies when appropriate to lean in that
direction like big bright glitzy with
amazing action scenes the last thing we
heard about the Green Lantern Corps
movie is the Jeff Jones is writing it
and it's gonna be a buddy cop movie
literally because Green Lantern's are
space police circling back around to
Wonder Woman 1984 and all those Steve
Trevor rumors the best one I've seen so
far is that Pedro Pascal is playing a
version of Maxwell Lord who's searching
the world for archeological artifacts
that will help him attain godlike power
he hires Minerva cheetah played by
Kristen Wiggs character to hunt down the
artifacts Indiana jones-style
one of them curses her and she turns
into Comic Book cheetah she goes after
him for revenge and then he turns to
Wonder Woman to help deal with the
problem and as a way to entice Wonder
Woman to help him because he's kind of a
dirtbag he offers to bring back Steve
Trevor using his power in the artifacts
so just looking at the promo pictures
they've released of him so far he's
definitely dressed like classic
comic-book Maxwell Lord in that suit so
that could be what's going on he's a
powerful telepath in the comics so there
are a number of ways he could manipulate
Wonder Woman or even just manipulate her
mind with Steve Trevor but the really
interesting thing that patty Jenkins
Chris Pine and gal gadot have all said
talking about Steve Trevor is that it is
the original version of Steve Trevor
legit come back to life he's a physical
person walking around with the fanny
pack not knowing what the hell's going
on in this mall so Chris Pine said that
his arc initially during wonderful
in 1984 when he does come back is a
reversal of Wonder Woman's arc at the
beginning of her first movie
she was the fish-out-of-water in World
War one era London this time he'll be
the fanny pack wearing fish-out-of-water
trying to acclimate all the weirdness of
the 80s when he comes back in this
Washington DC area
this is him talking about that fanny
pack and you were gonna be in the next
Wonder Woman yeah but it's been out for
a while even though you're really out we
were reincarnated or something I guess
something you haven't I can't tell you
about that it's called Wonder Woman 1984
because it is set in 1984 what's your
opinion of the fanny pack after wearing
on for this movie I got to tell you
something I love a fanny I'm with you I
like a fanny pack joke you know why I
like the fanny pack incredible storage
space mm-hmm your pants were not
weighted down by unnecessary back you
mean right and this is also why I'm
investigating a new thing which is the
suspender let me know in the comments
though how do you think he comes back
because there has got to be some godlike
power in play to physically bring him
back from death we got a whole bunch of
Super Bowl trailers coming up real soon
I'm not expecting a Wonder Woman 1984
trailer but I do think there's gonna be
New Avengers and game and a bunch of
Marvel stuff leave all your requests in
the comments below click here for my
brand new spider-man far from home
sinister 6 trailer video and click here
for my brand-new Game of Thrones Season
8 video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight